okay so the topic of this video is the
genetics inheritance pattern known as
autosomal dominance so let's get started
well remember the Henderson family if
you're in my biology class we met this
fictional family Dylan and Maria
Henderson they have a six-year-old
daughter named Sophia they have a
three-year-old son named Nicholas and
they just welcomed the birth of little
baby Joshua and we met them a few days
ago in class when we learned that Joshua
has the disorder PKU phenylketonuria an
autosomal an autosomal recessive
disorder and we learned that mr.
henderson and mrs. henderson each
heterozygous and this was autosomal
recessive where the disorder is
recessive and healthy is dominant but
we're going to learn a different
disorder today a different pattern today
we're gonna learn autosomal dominance
well let's expand this cartoon family
here let's look at Maria's side of the
family Maria happens to be the oldest of
three children she has two younger
brothers Lucas who is 29 years old and
Martin who is 21 years old and recently
their mother Mia has referred their
father Kevin to the doctor because Kevin
has become very unsteady while walking
and he seems to be more forgetful he's
also been dropping items that he holds
on to you know car keys and coffee mugs
and he's becoming very clumsy
so now we're bringing back our doctor
here and our doctor says hey you know
we're pretty sure that your father is
showing the early signs of Huntington's
disease it's an autosomal dominant
disorder so our doctor here is talking
to the three siblings Maria Lucas and
Martin well let's learn about autosomal
dominance first of all an autosome is a
non sex chromosome in this picture of a
karyotype here reminder that chromosome
23 the x and x chromosome if it's a
female or x and y if it's a male these
are the sex chromosomes but the other
chromosomes chromosomes 1 through 22 are
known as the autosomes there are no
genes on these chromosomes that
influence one's gender well that's what
an autosome is and so autosomal
disorders are caused by genes that are
found somewhere on either chromosome 1
through 22 an example would be
Huntington's disease the gene
responsible for Huntington's disease has
been located and it's been found on
chromosome 4 so the cause of
Huntington's disease is a gene located
on chromosome 4 chromosome 4 is an
autosome so Huntington's disease is
called an autosomal disorder and you
might have heard of Huntington's disease
because it's the disorder that shortened
the life of folk singer Woody Guthrie
who sang the song this land is your land
this land is my land and he passed at a
fairly young age due to Huntington's
disease well another example is a
disorder called familial
hypercholesterolemia I hope I pronounced
that right I'm more commonly just called
F F H the gene for FH has been located
on chromosome 19 chromosome 19 is an
autosome so the disorder FH is an
autosomal disorder
well let's go back to our three siblings
here you know last time I was here to
discuss baby Joshua you said that he had
an autosomal recessive disorder how is
this different
and our doctor says well if the disorder
is recessive then a sufferer must
inherit two alleles to have the disorder
because if the disorder is recessive
healthy is dominant and the disorder is
recessive and so look at this
combination homozygous dominant would
result in a healthy individual
heterozygous would result in a healthy
individual who would still be called a
carrier and then the only way to have an
autosomal recessive disorder is if you
inherit not one lowercase allele from
let's say the mom but also a second
lowercase allele from the dad you would
have to be homozygous recessive to have
disorders like PKU cystic fibrosis and
sickle cell disease those are examples
of autosomal recessive disorders but if
the disorder is dominant then a sufferer
only needs you inherit one allele to
have the disorder and that's what we're
learning today in this video so the rule
for an autosomal dominant disorder that
sufferers only have to inherit one
allele to have the disorder notice how
our key is changed the disorder is now
equivalent to the capital dominant
letter and healthy is recessive and so
when we look at these two combinations
here a person can have one of these two
combinations to have the disorder a
person can either be homozygous dominant
or heterozygous the only way to have the
healthy healthy non disordered genotype
would be to be homozygous recessive
that's the only combination that would
result in being healthy and not having
the disorder so as we just said a moment
ago there's actually two ways that a
person can inherit this disorder now the
two ways are not the same if a person is
homozygous dominant they tend to have a
more severe version of
the disorder if a person is heterozygous
they tend to have a milder or more or
less severe a moderate version of the
disorder and the only way to be healthy
as we said a moment ago is to have the
genotype known as homozygous recessive
well if we looked at the pedigree of
these five people Kevin the dad Mia the
mom and then the three siblings
the doctor says Dino if anyone else in
your father's side of the family has
suffered from HD Huntington's disease
and Martin says you know our father was
adopted so we don't really know anything
about his side of the family and in a
pedigree if you ever see brackets
surrounding a symbol that that means
that the person's been adopted so in
this case we don't really have any other
information about their father's side of
the family and our doctor says well he
must have inherited this disorder either
from his biological mother or biological
father because he has the disorder I can
go ahead and color in Kevin's square and
since he's 55 years old he has to be
heterozygous he has the milder or the
less severe version of the disorder if
he was homozygous dominant then he
probably would not have lived to be 55
years old
now your mother does not have the
disease and as we learned if you don't
have the disease if you're healthy then
the only way to be healthy would be the
homozygous recessive genotype so your
mother must have passed along a healthy
recessive allele to each of you but each
of you has a 50-50 chance of inheriting
this disorder from your father
notice from the square there there is a
50% chance that Maria Lucas and Martin
could inherit their dad's capital H and
if that happens they're gonna have the
disorder Huntington's disease well let's
examine this punnett square here we know
their dad Kevin has the disease
Huntington's disease and as we said he's
heterozygous and we know their mom is
fine she's healthy she does not have the
disorder so she has to be homozygous
recessive when we fill in the punnett
square we see that there are two squares
out of four that result in a person with
the disorder and there are two squares
out of four that result in a person that
is healthy so each of them Rio Lucas and
Martin they have a 50/50 chance of
inheriting this life-threatening
disorder called Huntington's disease and
so that's where we get the 50/50 odds
from
and Maria sighs you know I'd like to be
tested as soon as possible I have three
kids I need to know my genetic future
you know the doctor says you know these
test results will either be reassuring
or devastating before testing is offered
each of you will need to speak with the
therapist to help you cope with the
results whatever they might be you know
we could arrange a genetic testing if
that's something that you wish but
please think it over
so before we conclude this this story
here try to pause this video and try to
answer this question I'm gonna go ahead
and show the answer in three two one
okay so now that you had a chance to
work through this problem there's the
square representing Marcus and the
circle representing Betty and it says
Betty and Marcus they met at a support
clinic they've been attending to help
them cope with the knowledge of their
illness with Huntington's disease so
each of them Marcus and Betty must have
Huntington's disease now because they're
old enough to Wed and produce a child
they have to be adults which means
they're heterozygous because if this is
the moderate or the less severe version
and so people with with the moderate
less severe version live long enough to
reproduce and have children and they
would like to know the risk of having a
healthy child
now that Betty is pregnant so maybe
she's pregnant with a boy so we can plot
Marcus and Betty on the punnett square
now and when we do we fill in this
punnett square and we see that they can
actually have a child born with the
severe version of the disorder they
could have a child born with the
moderate version of the disorder they
could have had a child born with the
moderate version of the disorder or
there's a one in four chance they could
have a person a child born healthy so
the question says they would like to
know the risk of having a healthy child
now that Betty is pregnant well the
answer to this is there's only a 25%
chance that their child
we'll be born healthy so a few months
have gone by let's bring the siblings
back together for a conclusion Martin
the spokesperson says you know as you
know our Father has tested positive for
Huntington's disease Maria and I have
recently tested negative so they must be
homozygous recessive that's good news
sadly however Lucas has tested positive
for the Huntington's disease gene he
must have received their father's
dominant capital H allele and so the
entire family has been attending support
group meetings with Lucas we've been
encouraged and inspired by the story
shared from the other members and as we
wrap up you know if you're in my class
pause the video try to answer these
questions and I'm happy to check your
answers before a score after school one
day so I hope you found this video
helpful thanks for watching